[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
pour ce premier set 8 loisirs de l'année
2010 est vos idées sorties dans le
département on commence au tout avec le
sommaire de ce numéro c'est la rentrée
et le centre de musique baroque de
versailles a lancé son recrutement pour
la saison 2017-2018
nous recevrons l'administrateur de la
maîtrise pour nous en parler
une première à guyancourt en
l'adaptation théâtrale du célèbre roman
d'andré dhôtel sera jouée demain
mise en scène par l'auteur godefroy
ségal la pièce joue notre merveilleux et
poésie les détails dans ce magazine
enfin mélanie poquet nous présentera
suite curieuse un spectacle de danse sur
la thématique du petit chaperon rouge au
théâtre saint quentin en yvelines
mais d'abord un rappel dobbels qui a
débuté ce mercredi et continue jusqu'au
18 février
demain à partir de 14h le caricaturiste
qui gribouille tout viendra à la
rencontre des habitants de la
médiathèque anatole-france de trappes
les plus courageux pourront se faire
tirer le portrait avec humour et pour
les mangaka en herbe un atelier manga
mercredi à la médiathèque jean rousselot
de guyancourt ce sera avec le
dessinateur kara de 14 heures à 18
heures toutes les informations à
retrouver sur internet
et comme chaque année le premier week
end de janvier c'est le traditionnel
concours de la compagnie d'arc
d'elancourt au complexe sportif europe
un concours sélectif pour les
championnats de france de tir à l'arc
les parties s'y prend les participants
s'affronteront samedi et dimanche
le dimanche après midi est consacré aux
duels on écoute le président de la
compagnie nous parler des archers il
était au micro d'haussmann vendeurs des
tous les archers confirmés peuvent venir
s'y inscrire on accueille 320 marché sur
le week-end sur le samedi et le dimanche
donc 300 marché qui viennent qui
viennent tirer
on a une majorité bien sûr de darche et
qui viennent
du département de la région on a
accueilli déjà des les archers de
belgique
on a des archers de rouen qui viennent
aussi
et je le disais en titre le centre de
musique baroque de versailles démarre
l'année avec son recrutement pour la
saison 2017-2018 de miss khroma là
l'administrateur de la maîtrise du
centre nous a rejoint en plateau bonjour
denis
bonjour alors je le disais le
recrutement à qui s'adresse vous
recherchez des pages et des chantres ce
que vous pouvez rappeler un petit peu
qu'est ce que sont les profils que vous
recherchez justement voilà tout à fait
donc cet inter écoles une maîtrise et
donc qui est composée d'enfants et
d'adultes
alors les enfants il rentre chez nous
dès l'âge de 4 ans en atelier
d'initiation vocale sur le hors temps
scolaire et ensuite à partir du ce1 ils
peuvent intégrer les classes à horaires
aménagés de l'éducation nationale ce
sont des enfants qui sont scolarisés à
l'école va plaire à versailles et
ensuite au collège ramon dont qui suit
voilà une vaste formation vocale
musicale scénique
pendant tout le temps de leur scolarité
on s'adresse justement aux scolaires et
il ya des horaires aménagés
voilà exactement alors c'est un
dispositif de l'éducation nationale qui
est très connu qui existent dans de très
nombreuses écoles et académies en france
qui permet à ces enfants de bénéficier
d'un mi temps scolaire donc le matin ils
vont suivre lorsque l'arrêté normale à
l'école élémentaire ou au collège et
l'après-midi vienne aut cmbv pour suivre
les cours de technique vocale le chant
choral le solfège
les cours d'interprétation avec les
accompagnateurs donc une formation
extrêmement enrichissante et
passionnante
donc c'est pour les enfants et pour les
adultes alors comment ça se passe et
alors pour les adultes c'est un objectif
un petit peu différent puisque là on
recrute des adultes en formation
professionnelle est l'objectif de ce
cursus de trois ans et d'en faire
véritablement de jeunes chanteurs
choristes solistes qui ensuite vont
exercer leur carrière leur métier de
chanteur professionnel
donc ils sont recrutés sur concours il
ya toute une procédure qui est mise en
oeuvre qui est ouverte ailleurs dès
maintenant pour la rentrée 17 sur
d'autres sites et donc les différents
candidats vont devoir présenter leur
candidature réaliser un enregistrement
pour pouvoir ensuite intégrer notre
école de formation professionnelle
un petit mot quand même parce que cette
année un anniversaire particulier pour
le centre de musique baroque de
versailles vous fêtez vos trente ans
voilà ce qu'il ya des des grains grand
anniversaire un grand événement est
prévu
oui alors y'a énormément d'événements
tout au long de l'année 2010 est
puisqu'on en effet le centre avait été
créée en 1987
parmi ces nombreux événements on peut
citer le tout premier qui va se produire
en l'occurrence dès cette semaine qui
est la création d'un spectacle très
original qui est une parodie pour
marionnettes musiciens et chanteurs
d'une tragédie lyrique du xviie siècle
en fait tout le prends répertoire
sérieux du xviie siècle qui était
proposé à l'académie royale de musique
était ensuite parodier sous forme de
spectacle populaire est extrêmement
joyeux dans les foires comme par exemple
la foire de saint germain à paris et
donc ses spectacles qui reprenait des
extraits de ces différentes oeuvres mais
en les tournant en dérision rassembler
des interprètes et des
d des marionnettes été présenté sur un
théâtre castellet et donc dans cette
perspective bien nous réalisons cette
fois ci une parodie dati ce qui est donc
une tragédie lyrique de lully avec des
marionnettes qui ont été créés par jean
philippe desrousseaux l'ensemble les
lunaisiens d' arnaud marzorati et ce
sera un spectacle qui va être créée à la
valette à malte
dès la semaine prochaine en l'occurrence
au festival de musique baroque de malte
le public pourra le découvrir également
le plus de 50 ans et alors ensuite on
leur trouvera effectivement en france en
tournée un certain nombre de fois parce
que ce sont des productions extrêmement
importante que l'on fait tourner pendant
plusieurs saisons consécutives pour que
à la fois les spectateurs français mais
aussi des spectateurs étrangers puissent
découvrir la spécificité de cette
parodie de musique baroque française et
vous mettez justement en valeur la
musique baroque régulièrement notamment
à travers les jeudis musicaux à la
chapelle royale est également un
spectacle la semaine prochaine les
chanteurs participe au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines à l'opéra
chimène ou le syn alors on va en parler
juste après je vous propose tout d'abord
de regarder un petit extrait
[Musique]
pour jamais pour jamais
alors est-ce que vous pouvez nous
présenter un petit peu ce spectacle les
adultes et les enfants participent ou
uniquement les adultes n'est pas admis
et en l'occurrence les anciens étudiants
de notre cursus de formation
professionnelle on a recréé un coeur
avec les anciens chantres qui
aujourd'hui sont des choristes
professionnels et ils participent à
cette production donc de la re création
d'une tragédie lyrique de sacchini
sakinis c'est l'un des grands
compositeurs qui a été invité en france
par marie antoinette et qui a développé
en france l'esthétique italienne qui
était à la mode aux sous le règne de
louis saez est donc cette tragédie
lyrique qui a été créée en 1783
tout d'abord au théâtre du château de
fontainebleau puis à l'académie royale
de musique de paris va être recréée
grâce à un partenariat une coproduction
entre le cnpv et l'arcal la compagnie de
théâtre musical francilienne avec
également le soutien d'arcadie de la
spedidam et grâce également une
résidence au sein de la scène nationale
de saint quentin
merci beaucoup en tout cas de nul est
revenu sur notre plateau pour nous
présenter ce spectacle et la période de
recrutement du centre de musique baroque
de versailles toutes les informations
sont à retrouver sur internet si vous
êtes intéressés merci beaucoup merci
et ce samedi à guyancourt le metteur en
scène ou godefroy ségal présente sa
première adaptation théâtrale du roman
incontournable le pays où on n'arrive
jamais d'andré dhôtel le spectateur
embarque dans un voyage sous forme de
récits merveilleux plus de détails dans
ce reportage dans les comptes relais
situés au nord jusqu'aux reins ou
jusqu'au port d'anvers ce sont des
centaines de collines et de pleine
charge et de richesses
andré dhôtel le disait dans son roman il
n'existe pas une forêt mais mille forêt
le pays on n'arrive jamais un
chef-d'oeuvre merveilleux de 1955 à re
découvrir au théâtre
moi j'avais découvert ce livre
collégiens et en fait il m'a jamais trop
quitter il m'a accompagné il m'a fait
découvrir l'oeuvre immense d'andré
dhôtel
j'ai mis des années en fait avant de me
décider à tenter l'adaptation du pays où
on n'arrive jamais qui est pas simple
parce que en fait c'est un roman
initiatique c'est un roman d'itinérance
ou on passe d'un lieu à un autre quelque
chose qui en fait anti théâtrale quoi
qu'il défie les lois du théâtre en
création depuis un an la pièce est jouée
pour la première fois l'histoire reprend
celle de gaspard le jeune garçon se lie
d'amitié avec un enfant fugitif à la
recherche de son pays
un récit enchanteur qui rend au monde
toute sa poésie
aujourd'hui j'ai vu un éclair quittera
bel arc-en-ciel
pour moi ça a été un message de vie qui
dit à l'homme regardait la nature
regarder les forêts regarder les a
respectés les plantes respecter les
champignons il n'y a pas besoin de faire
des milliers de kilomètres pour voyager
voyager autour de votre maison
intéressez vous à ce qui se passe
écoutez lisez regardez quelque chose qui
a changé moi qui a changé en fait ma
vision de la littérature de la ville une
de là il n'a pu m'a plus jamais jamais
jamais quitté quoi un voyage fantastique
qui parlera aux petits comme aux grands
enfants par un jeu de toiles peintes et
de vidéos
la compagnie in cauda les emmènera
jusqu'au bout du monde
le rendez-vous junior de la semaine
c'est de la danse contemporaine pour les
plus jeunes avec une histoire d'un connu
de tous le petit chaperon rouge
bonjour mme hélène bonjour caves et les
aventures de ce petit chaperon rouge
sont à découvrir jusqu'au 7 janvier au
théâtre national de saint quentin en
yvelines
un spectacle d'une quarantaine de
minutes et s'est créé par la compagnie
québécoise cas public alors hélène
blackburn a choisi ce conte par un
attachement par souvenir le petit
chaperon rouge étant le premier petit
livre qu'on lui a offert écoutez le
buste décide de créer quand même un
climat qui était pas ce que j'appelle
mon film doha pour enfin me décrire à
fait à cette tension pouvoir jouer avec
les tensions et relâchement de récit
c'est une histoire qui était une matière
en fait c'est plus une matière qu'une
histoire me sentais moins nous besoin de
le raconter que je ça me permettait de
l'évoqué pas de ses fruits quand même
nom ça faisait compris vous l'avez vu en
plus dans l'interview hélène le dit avec
le sourire la troupe existe depuis
maintenant 25 ans et ça fait même quinze
ans qu'elle fait des spectacles que pour
enfants ou à voir en famille tout est
adapté à l'âge des spectateurs ça
s'adresse même dès l'âge de deux ans on
joue sur les peurs du petit pain
chaperon rouge mais il ya de la poésie
la musique et les mouvements rassure
elle pln elle mais nous a rassurés y'a
pas de pleurs à la fin elle est danseur
utilise le langage des signes
car l'un des danseurs et sourd c'est ça
les sort on le voit à l'image alors
l'une des reines il est équipé pourtant
un pour entendre mais ça a inspiré la
compagnie ça fait très longtemps qu'ils
travaillent ensemble et ça rentre c'est
très graphique on le voit j'ai vu les
répétitions c'est c'est très intéressant
et c'est par contre la ligne est la
langue des signes québécoise donc les
français ne comprennent pas
nécessairement un petit chaperon rouge
le canadien avec trois loups également
ça c'est une petite nouveauté dans ce
spectacle et ce n'est pas pour eux c'est
pas parce que c'est pour les enfants que
c'est tout aussi simple pour autant
non c'est pas tout à fait ça mais ce
sont quand même des petites saynètes ça
joue sur la lumière la musicalité pas
nécessairement d'histoire mme ce sont
des évocations mais il y a beaucoup de
technique il y a beaucoup de
virtuosité dans les mouvements et s'est
aussi associée une multitude de petites
éléments sur scène écouter ce qu'ont dit
les blackburn
j'ai passé mon immense coffre à jouets
mon coffre à jouet idéal donc on a on a
un trait qui vient donner à la fois le
temps et l'espace jours ici on réfère à
beaucoup d'objets qui sont issus du
quotidien des enfants donc ça crée un
espèce d'effet de reconnaissance par un
teint ça nous permet de dégager une
certaine poésie parce qu'on les place
sur scène et on les utilise de manière
différente et pour découvrir ce que fera
jouets direction le théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines dernière
représentation ce samedi 7 janvier à 18
heures c'est la fin de ce set 8 loisirs
merci beaucoup de nous avoir suivis je
vous retrouve vendredi prochain pour un
nouveau numéro je vous souhaite un bon
week-end et une excellente année 2010
est
[Musique]
oh